the Hamilton tiger-cats in the CFL
taking on the Montreal Alouettes in
Johnny Manziel making a CFL debut he
threw none other than just four picks
four of them and they showed a shot of
the defensive coordinator I'm like holy
crap is that Jerry Glanville and sure
enough it was and now sure enough it is
right here on the Rich Eisen show former
coach the Oilers and Falcons a guy who I
haven't spoken to and forever in a day
now at the Hamilton tiger-cats Jerry
Glanville here on the show how are you
Jerry why you're your introduction in
your promo you spend way too much money
on just delivering the show you need to
get better guests no come on now Jerry
well I mean we're showing it we're
showing a shot of you right now on the
television screen straight from the
Hamilton tiger-cats media God have you
wearing sunglasses it's fantastic come
on now Jerry this is great so how did
you wind up with the Hamilton tiger-cats
coordinating the defense well June Jones
of course was my assistant and in the
NFL and then I was June Jones assistant
at Hawaii when we had those great teams
in Hawaii and then he became the head
coach up here and called me and said
let's go do it one more time nobody he
said the defensive player and anybody
come on up so we're up here trying to
try to win a game or two well you want a
game certainly last Friday night Jerry
what were your impressions of Manziel
out there he had no chance because you
know we we were able to you know my
whole life is kind of funny the game was
over I got a text from Bernie Kosar and
Bernie Kosar we got a text from Joe
Theismann and they said collapse the
pocket bring one in the face and played
tight man I think I've seen it before
yes you know we collapse the pocket
scoop the guy outside to his face and
played not one snappers own so all of a
sudden quarterbacks have bad days as you
know now of course absolutely and it was
his first opportunity up there in Canada
do you see somebody in there that was
out there on that field that has the
ability to excel at this sport do you
think Jerry at this level
well what I did I went back and watched
all the games he played at a.m. we had a
long train right we had a five hour
train ride to to to the game site so as
I was riding to Train one of my guys put
on computer and I watched everything
that he did at a.m. and then that night
we made about three little wrinkles
which would negate any success that he
had at a.m. what is a shock to me is
that what we did know SEC coordinator
ever put on what we ran nobody ever ran
at him and and you just wondered the SEC
coordinators are highly paid but there
must be highly overpaid because our deal
we put together riding on a train you
think somebody else would have run that
out that's the first time you saw that
package are you serious nobody attempted
in the SEC what you did in the CFL on
Friday night no not one guy we looked at
all the film I said well he's having
success because he this is not happening
in his playing zone he's playing he's
throwing the number-3 slant in the zone
and he's making the zone guy come up
with the play fake well all you know is
you know what welcome to pro football
this ain't bull the bull
Jerry Glanville joining us here on the
Rich Eisen show so I guess last question
on this for you is do you think he has
what it takes do you think he has the
skill set to succeed
certainly when he's seen stuff for the
first time I think you know what you
never do and this is my rule with with
Jim but he works for me and my rule
forever you never ever give up on deep
ball accuracy and in our practices when
he was with us he has deep ball accuracy
and if you can throw a 55-yard iran
where it's supposed to be you know that
then you do other things to help better
protection better receivers but he's got
deep ball accuracy so I'd never give up
Jerry Glanville joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show why you right
the trainman I mean and I know that
that's what's going on in the CFL but I
mean why are you why I know and June
Jones called up and asked you why are
you doing this
Jerry I love ball you know if you don't
love ball you don't do this but you know
I look you know we put together defense
I got three four real good assistants
and you love this we gave up one
touchdown 11 quarters that's never
happened up here we've gone into four
games at halftime where we given up 25
yards past and just just excel just to
be better than what everybody thinks
you're gonna beat it that's the
challenge would you want to coach in the
NFL again yeah but again you know who's
gonna hire me it's kind of funny people
say go get an NFL job everybody that
would recommend me and love me as a
coach is dead so it's hard to call up
your people you know so you don't think
you know so that there would be people
that knew anybody who had worked with
you you want to hire you Jerry
well you never know I mean if we play
good I mean if I heard from five NFL
teams after that game same game useful
yeah because I think they were shocked
what they and what they saw and they
realized they'd seen that before
a few years back and you know who knows
who knows but the bottom line is I enjoy
every day you know we work 17 hours a
day seven days a week can't wait to jump
out of bed and go for another I got you
so who was the best player you ever
coach Jerry where as a head coach in the
NFL well yeah it's not a fair question I
tell you this because I've got seven
nine guys in the Hall of Fame but but
you know what claw Humphrey thanked me
for going the Hall of Fame Deion Sanders
I said they're going to Hall of Fame
with or without middle Hall of Fame at
your grandma's coaches so when you say
who's what I remember is guys that
weren't good enough when you started in
two years later wins your ballgame
because of effort coaching
occasionally offseason another goodness
that's the guy should remember I mean I
love coaching Deion Sanders and LEM
Barney they're the two best corners in
the Hall of Fame but they were going
there whether I coach them or not so
what what's your favorite story about
Deion what knew how special he was your
people know I was coaching them in the
press copper you know people in the
press and in Vienna press conversation
you've gotta hate Deion Sanders and I
says I do
hey good hey he dances after every time
he scores he dances in the end zone I
said let me tell you something I hope he
dances three times the game you know
that's just hotter me this is you know
people think you get upset over stuff
like that and what people don't know
about yeah
in practice you got to be the show team
we get 15 plays of our work now let's
say you play Minnesota and you now you
get he's the Minnesota Corn even when he
was a show team in practice he did not
allow anybody to catch up all out even
when we were supposed to be the enemy he
never let anybody catch a ball in
practice that's why he said the whole
thing
have you ever spoke have you spoken to
Favre lately recently because obviously
he's a different person than the one
that you coached Gerry oh I spoke to
sissies since he's uh you know got out
of football but I haven't talked to him
in two three years what was he like when
you're out of jury he was a young
stallion that hadn't been broken yet no
bear Goldman you know Udyr that age and
you got that kind of money and I think
the problem with all young kids I think
this is part of the problem with Johnny
Manziel and you're not planed it's easy
to drift into trouble if you're playing
and have the responsibility that your
team's counting on you you pay more
attention and you do less things I think
both guys were their problems were
magnified because they were sitting the
bench
couple more minutes left with jerry
glanville hamilton tiger-cats defensive
coordinator currently in longtime NFL
coach head coach here on the show are
you still leaving tickets for Elvis yeah
no I just I bring it with me what do you
mean you bring him others do you
practice with me and I take him to the
games he's got his own his own past so
when was the last time that you'd left a
ticket for Elvis oh man I guess we were
playing New England in Memphis and a
preseason game and Raymond Barry was
their head coach and the halftime was
dedicated to him and Memphis and June
said will they dedicate the halftime to
who was only in the ticket and that
thing sort of took a life of his own
after that it's so how many tickets in
your career did you leave aggregate
rolling game and how about this I walked
into the fountains and on the Left
alcohol whatever they call the Hall of
Fame whatever they called the Falcons
and there's a Jerry Glanville section I
go over to the Jerry Glanville section
to read it in the Hall of Fame section
in the Atlanta Falcons building says in
Jerry Glanville left two tickets for
Elvis for every game I never did it one
time
are you saying yeah you would think
where I worked would get it right but
the Internet the internet says
difference on internet it's the truth
it's like CNN fake news every day so you
know so you never left a ticket for
Elvis Presley except yeah okay that's it
that one time in all right last one for
you then Jerry one of my favorite wired
moments in the history of NFL Films is
you telling somebody that the NFL stood
for not for long do you do you have a
CFL what CFL stands for no but a very
good one because the officiating hasn't
changed I better find one I didn't know
where that weekend that's the first time
by the way IRA said that my lapis I was
so mad what caused it the week before
we were playing the Broncos and Elway
went off on the scramble and Johnny mise
was my star outside linebacker and he
didn't want to hit the quarterback he
thought in the quarterback which traded
on blue as me sent him the surgery so
the next game were intemperate I told
all the linebackers the quarterback goes
out on the scramble protect yourself hit
him don't let him hit you and we bumped
the quarterback and that's when the guy
threw the flag I asked if he was a
boola-boola official the last game he
did before he did that program was a
Vanderbilt homecoming which of course
they play at six a year so that's the
kind of people you deal with not so he
ran a pet store you got a pet store
Monday to Thursday
he threw flags on you on Sunday yes oh
my gosh
Jerry I got to catch up with you more
often thanks for calling him really
appreciate it Thanks you gonna jerry
glanville calling in the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience